optimal room at this altitude I can run
flat out for a half-mile before my hands
start shaking can I also post now I'm a
cybernetic organism living tissue over
metal endoskeleton this episode is
brought to you by wordpress my go-to
platform for blogging writing online
creating websites everything I love
WordPress to bits my site every site
just about that I have is run on
WordPress and the lead developer of
WordPress Matt Mullenweg has appeared on
this podcast many times the very first
episode in particular is amazing the
second I took a ton of notes on so you
should check it out but WordPress where
do I even begin I mean the New Yorker
uses it jay-z Beyonce they use it 5:38
TechCrunch Ted CNN time whether you are
looking to create a personal blog a
business site both neither something
else you'll make a huge impact when you
build your website on wordpress.com and
directly from some friends at Google I'm
not going to quote them by name but they
say that WordPress offers the best
out-of-the-box SEO the search engine
optimization imaginable so if you're on
WordPress you immediately have a leg up
on everybody else on search engines and
so forth in my experience I'm no medical
doctor of search engine optimization but
I will say that I used WordPress for
years and fell in love with it to the
extent that I became very close friends
with Matt and then became an investor
slash advisor to automatic which runs
wordpress.com that is how much I believe
in this and that's how a lot of my most
successful products and investments have
come about because I'm in love with X
and then I seek out X nearly 30% of the
Internet is run on WordPress and that
includes everything from the huge sites
that I mentioned to neighborhood sites
and it is super easy
to get started there's no need to worry
about security or upgrades or hosting
they offer 24/7 support and handle all
of that which allows you to focus on
creating the highest quality content you
can with the least amount of friction I
don't have to worry about downtime I
don't have to worry about getting
emergency emails if I'm on vacation or
something like that and WordPress is my
go-to solution for all of this I trust
all of my most important text on the
Internet to WordPress and they can't buy
that with a sponsorship they can't buy
that with anything I want uptime uptime
uptime and quality and that is what I
have selected after everything that I've
looked at so check it out go to
WordPress that's wor DP re SS com
WordPress comp or slash Tim to receive
15% off of your website today
that's wordpress.com forward slash PIM
this episode is brought to you by
99designs I've used 99designs for years
for all sorts of graphic design needs
whether you need a logo website cover
anything else 99designs was created to
make great designs accessible to
everyone and to make the process of
getting designs much much easier so when
I first started out for instance testing
prototype covers and getting prototype
covers for the 4-hour body
I want to contest route that is one
option this is a great solution if
you're looking for fast affordable
design work and the ability to choose
from dozens of options risk-free let's
say you need something late night quick
turnaround well people in other time
zones other countries can also help you
solve that problem since then I've
worked with 99 designs on a separate
path or a different option and that is
the one-to-one project service so in a
number of cases and I'll give you one
example when I wanted to create the
cover for my audio book The Tao of
Seneca this was a very important project
to me I decided to use their one-to-one
project service and with this service
you can invite a specific designer to
your project agree on a price and then
work together until you're satisfied and
they allow you to iterate provide
feedback and all this stuff and I
haven't shared it yet but we also got
something credibly good
really some of the best illustrations
I've ever seen from using this
one-to-one project service with a
handful of different designers and
illustrators it blew my mind 99 designs
makes this all very easy and efficient
so you can check out the Tao of Seneca
design and other work that I and your
fellow listeners for that matter have
done on 99 designs at 99 designs com
forward slash Tim and right now you can
get a free $99 upgrade on your first
design again that's 99 designs dot-com
for slash Tim gutentag this gentleman is
Tim Ferriss welcome to another episode
of Tim Ferriss show we heard is my job
to deconstruct world-class performers of
all different types this episode
features Kyle Maynard and you're going
to want to check him out I promise and
on Twitter you can say hello at Kyle
Maynard Kyl EMA yna Rd people often ask
me who inspires you who do you look up
to one immediate answer is Kyle Maynard
despite being born without full arms or
legs he has gone on to achieve feats of
athleticism and much more that most
people would only dream of they might
not even think of dreaming of these
things this includes being the first
quadruple amputee to climb Mount
Kilimanjaro without the aid of
prosthetics being inducted into the
National Wrestling Hall of Fame as in
collegiate wrestling believe it and
competing professionally in mixed
martial arts he is just a female and he
actually had a chance to do a short
wrestling demo with takedowns that
almost broke my knee and then an arm
throw on video which you can see and in
this episode we cover many stories that
Kyle has never discussed or shared
publicly before the audio comes from my
new TV show fearless and that is fear
less with less in parentheses because
it's about learning to fear less where I
interview worthless performers on stage
about how they've overcome doubt
conquered fear and made some of their
toughest decisions you can watch the
entire first episode with David Blaine
the illusionist and endurance artist for
free at att.net forward slash fearless
and that's ATT
that forward slash fearless into watch
all of the episodes there are ten of
them including the episode with Kyle
please a Direct TV now so you does
Google DirecTV now Direct TV with one T
so not Direct TV but DirecTV we recorded
three hours of material in only one hour
was used for the TV show this podcast
episode is almost entirely new content
that did not appear on television so I
hope you enjoy it as much as I did so
without further ado here is the
incredible Kyle Maynard
welcome to fearless I'm your host Tim
Ferriss and on this stage will be
deconstructing world-class performers of
all types to uncover the specific
tactics they've used overcome doubt
tackle hard decisions and ultimately
succeed on their own terms
my guest tonight is a member of the
National Wrestling Hall of Fame New York
Times bestselling author and it's
summited Mount Kilimanjaro among others
he inspires audiences around the world
with this message any Congress
challenges with this own unique style
please welcome to a stage athlete author
and mountaineer Kyle Maynard
little around the world itself
everybody's going boom how many siblings
do you have three sisters and her sister
yeah what doesn't kill you yeah I grew
up with one little brother so I was the
bastard and that was like you said I'm
like I need to try this wrestling move
on you're like running around the house
don't run away I know it's going to be
fun now as I was on the inflicting side
unfortunately there are a lot of grown
man I'd rather fight my sister you dad
seems like tough dude that bad dude like
tough former wrestler
I'm sure he's loving that right now I
really hate often see them for their 20s
out in fairness but how were your
parents parenting styles different there
was a difference for sure and I think it
was it was good balance wrestling my dad
was like he'd want to be be the finesse
wrestler you know and my mom was like
she told me if you put somebody enough
pain on the mat with you like they'll
find a way to get out he'll find a way
to get off of that and like that was
issues like had this like tenacity like
a Cobra Kai right exactly totally take
the leg it was perfect back what mom
baseball back when did your grandparents
enter the picture in terms of your close
relationship with them like hours after
I was born and they were there the whole
time
and what was your what was your
relationship like with your with your
grandparents I mean it's been the best
without them I mean they're everything
to me
you know I gotta like choke back the
tears sometimes to send my grandma so
she passed last year and it was really
the big moment for me in terms of kind
of like that awakener of like what is my
life about really you know my grandma
you know um you know so she kind of said
this you know from her experiences you
know in a like a religious background
but I think it can be sort of even like
a more universal sense if you apply this
like she said that Kyle like God doesn't
make mistakes
you know like
take that to go and mean to even like
the universe doesn't make mistakes right
that there and and whether or not that's
true it doesn't matter but it's a cool
it's an interesting place to come from
right the Stoics talked a lot about like
fate and like how we're on this path in
this trajectory and like whether or not
that's true it doesn't really matter but
if we go and you know act as if is so
and that things are as they should be
it's just a better place to be I think I
used to pray every night like when I was
a kid I go just like waste wish that I
could wake up and have arms legs you
know if I had spent my entire life
focused on that if it would have been a
different life definitely but she was
everything I mean she she's I think
that's the most powerful lesson that she
ever taught me was on least to go around
and grocery stores together just up and
down the aisles of the grocery store and
sometimes you know when we would meet
people I mean she would just she'd we
teach me said as soon as people hear
your voice let me see your face and they
shake your hand they'll totally forget
about the disability and you know it's
like a embedded like hypnotic command
almost you know it's like that's like so
much of my life has been colored by that
everybody that I meet now you know I
want to meet them and then 15 minutes
after it's not really the disabilities
not like that big of a deal yeah so
grandma Betty but now I can it's kind of
funny to this like I could read people's
eyes in terms of like you know almost
like you can see like subtitles for only
across sometimes right I go to like
shake somebody's hand and 99% of the
time I get a normal handshake back
whatever fist bump you know and then
like that 1% of time or less maybe one
out of a couple hundred I see this like
just fear and panic right you got to
shake their hand and they're like pause
and it's like guy does it have an arm
what is it you wanted me to do and I
just hang out and wait they come in for
like a backward elbow bump or something
like
like thanks bro that was awesome
occasionally I like how you process that
could work
what about your grandfather he my
grandpa too one super smart and I did
not inherit those uh those genes he I
mean like super smart he was like
valedictorian and engineers like you
know value touring at University of
Illinois as an engineer I mean he was
and with his mindset him and a dad my
dad is a engineer as well and they
really you know we're just great at
being able to figure out ways to be able
to go and adapt different things you
know and like that the actual tools of
what would be helpful problem solvers
yeah totally man I didn't learn to swim
believe it or not till I was in my 30s
when did you learn to swim I was I is
funny I was on Howard Stern and he
called my dad a dick for this but my dad
basically put me in the middle of pool
taught me how to float on my back and as
soon as he thought that I was like good
and I got it then he got out of the pool
and he was like now figure out how to
get out okay we really start crying is
straight to the bottom of the pool right
:
but you know kind of yeah it's like
probably four years old like that three
or four Wow
was the writing if you had writing
eating swimming was the most difficult
of those and is there something else
that I'm missing aside from asking girls
out that was particularly difficult for
you the physical stuff was was less
taxing to kind of like figure out I kind
of had this idea this belief like I've
you know that there would always be a
way there'd be some tool driving in
particular was a little bit trickier you
know a little bit older because it was
um I want to be in terms of like the
adaptations and equipment that I use a
lot more sort of Spartan right like I
want things to be very simple very
mechanical like very low a few points of
failure and first vehicle that this
group an amazing group that helps people
with spinal injuries in Atlanta wanted
to go and have me drive is this massive
this massive Ford van and it was like
this huge thing with like it was like at
these touchscreen computers that is back
in like two
and two or three right so you could cut
screen computers in like joysticks or
they you know gas the break and I'm like
all like this is crazy right I'm driving
in like tiny lanes in Atlanta rush-hour
traffic with this like giant deathtrap
like it was just this tank that's going
down barreling down the highway and I'm
like no never again not doing that again
you know like not control bleeding on
the freaking highway like there's no way
and like so I just came winter eject but
now I mean in so they have pedals that
drive just a second SUV and it's just
got basically lifted up an extended
pedals are very simple you can pop in my
car and drive it and it's like just put
your legs underneath it and the you know
he's my left foot to hit the brake and
my right foot to hit the gas and grabs
turn alarms and my mountain guide friend
actually who's done some pretty scary
things like climbed Everest and stuff so
that's like one of these scariest
moments of his life was when he's
driving me for the first time I grabbed
my phone to like answer it where we're
trying I got I got like the Bluetooth
thing going now
I want to talk a little bit about Cub
Scouts just we just in general just for
and all the other people I want to talk
about a couple should I join no uh the
eye registering about a cave can you
talk a little bit about your experience
yeah I think this is like where I found
my my environment I found my homeland
you know it's like like Gimli and Lord
of the Rings or something you know I
shouldn't I
I mean a sub training environment I
realized it was like this great
equalizer so we went to this cave in
Indiana's in the Boy Scouts we had my
dad my grandpa were there and uh you
know because he got to crawl through
these like tunnels and yeah right it's
like he's tiny wet cave tunnels and I
was like awesome like just sprinted past
everybody right oh I so harder but
what drove you to the athletics and what
came first I guess street hockey was
that sort of the first competitive sport
I don't know I didn't so the first like
team sport that I played was was flip on
and then raffling but it was like I
always had this interest in sports I was
obsessed you know and had this delusion
as like you know I'd be in the NBA
someday or like you know I'd be like a
you know as big Atlanta Braves fan and
like John Smoltz or Greg Maddux like
throwing fast balls and you know change
ups and stuff like and I think the
really cool thing was was what my
parents did let me have this like had
this dream they didn't like squelch it
my mom is a little bit more pragmatic I
think so when I did go to play football
you know she was telling me that you
know you might be to play you might be
the water boy on the team they're gonna
find a place we're in in my head like I
said it you know I want to be a
quarterback I want to be throwing a
spiral touchdowns and it is interesting
how those dreams they didn't like and as
you kind of answers you know you can
relate right it's like the dreams you
may have had a certain point it didn't
manifest exactly how you saw them go but
it set you on this path and this journey
that then takes you down other turns and
corridors and you go into other
directions that you never would have
imagined before
so the EEOC's world strongest team start
with 10 pounds got up to 210 each arm
what what was that the world's strongest
chain for GNC that was bench press right
yeah so it was on basic I was 17 18
years old it was like a we just kind of
picked like a weight 240 pounds and I
just did as many repetitions like it's
sort of like a combine ask me out of the
situation and I ended up at the
competition's who did 23 repetitions of
that and weighed about like 120 pounds
of the time but it's just crazy because
like I think so I opened the gym about
eight years ago and you know frequently
when someone would come into the gym and
like talk to me a lot of times or not
just me but one of our coaches they
would go and point at somebody doing
something amazing there you would go and
say like there's no way I can go and do
that you know I hear that all the time
that's like a to me it's like you know
you have no idea where that person
started there's no idea like the massive
amount of failure that went in to being
able to go and get to that point where
then they were doing something awesome
but the difference was they stuck it out
they did the work and then that was
result so yeah you know it's like a I
think that could go back in time and
tell that ten-year-old like that was
really struggling like a some day you'd
be able to go and lift that later
travel the world has a speaker you know
had businesses and you know gates and
amazing girls or all that different
experiences or climbs from the highest
peaks in the world it I guess I could
tell that ten-year-old that you know it
would almost seem like make a fantasy
story yeah and I think that in coming
back that question that we talked about
a bike veteran you know and somebody
maybe that's a really hard spot you know
if they could talk to someone 10 or 20
years you know the version of themselves
10 or 20 years later after they had
really faced some of these fears that I
think that they would have their mind
blown as to what they'd be able to
achieve for sure this you mentioned the
gym which brings us to mind and I have
already alluded to this it was like the
red doorknob and success I'll get to my
question which is Georgia why did you
guys move to Georgia it was on my
grandparents moved down and this is I
guess what took spread JJ yeah
grandparents moved out I mean just like
yeah we're in Indiana and it's just the
was and it was like the snow and like
all that it was the best thing that
happened I think in doing the move and
going to Georgia but it was also a time
it felt like the worst you knows I tried
to stage a family coup d'etat to like
try to like overthrow my dad and go back
to Indiana you know it was like I just I
noticed that a lot you know now kind of
get to sort of quasi mentor and help a
lot of different kids with disabilities
and I noticed that the transitory
periods anytime like where there's a
major transition in someone's life with
a move or going say you're going from
middle school to high school or high
school to college or college to you like
the you know the world then it's it's
those periods of transition that are the
most difficult and because it's like my
friends in Indiana saw me as Kyle as
long as normal and now I've got to go in
like Rihanna ties an entire new group of
people in Georgia yeah how how did you I
mean I imagine the sports is huge
toolkit for that right I mean in jar
break a few dozen people they're like
I'm going to go Kyle good bodies enter a
war uh no better thing wanted to be his
friend so what what helped you in that
transition aside from the sports and
what was the self-talk or what did your
parents or grandparents say to you I
think they were very very much my mom
especially trying to constantly you know
she was she's like a big she's do is
talk about like psychosis Maddux you
know and all this stuff raised like she
knew she just would just talk about kind
of mind over matter and like just be
drilling things in my head if like
focusing on the positive and all that so
it was really I'm super glad that she
she had that perspective but you know it
wasn't always the case my my mind annoys
obviously go there and definitely
probably the one of the most difficult
transitions that I faced was going from
as a freshman University Georgia and
write a book and as you know when you go
and launch a book that it's like it
changes your life forty dramatically and
you know book to her and all this stuff
got to be on Oprah and Larry King when I
was 19 and it was like just I went from
being a full-time college student to
full-time business traveler overnight
and in my community people knew me and
they knew you know not that like the
disability and stuff like that wasn't as
you know didn't make it that big of an
issue will it be gone and traveling
especially I was traveling by myself
then many people looked at me very
differently and you know of course I
want to help and things like that and I
think I've had some pretty hilarious
events where it was like for sure I
learned that one of my like bigger
challenges was like accepting help so
there were some times where I knew that
it would just be better and easier if I
like whatever it was get it on my own
right one time I'm in the New York
Airport mu Guardia there's a really
super steep jet way and this guy and I
get a little bit of an argument where he
tells me he works at the airport he's
telling me he has to push my wheelchair
down this jet way I'm like nah I'd be
better you know better if I did it like
he's like no I have to liability I'm
like we go back and forth finally and
giving but this guy was like the cost
human being I've ever seen litter
and he goes and takes about three steps
down the jetway he gets his foot caught
in the back of my wheelchair and he goes
down so he doesn't just like let go he
just launched me down the jello and I'm
fed up and I can see the people their
eyes at the bottom like this is it he's
comment like what are we she's beautiful
and I tried to grab the wall to slow
myself down and it was like this big
streak of blood came now CSI crime
seeing it I'm like wow and I at the
bottom of me or half and all that and
like flipped up Sharon I just laughing
hysterically when I survived and like it
you're like good liability grabbers come
on and I was like dude just Saul good
never ever help me again all right
stop helping me my coach used to stay
after in practice and he would literally
tuck his arms and just leave and wrestle
from my perspective know and try to for
hours like just try to figure out moves
they could go and do I think a lot of
times do we look at things we forget
like you look at one person to achieve
something great and we're like oh man
that one that that person right we don't
see the massive amount of people the
hundreds of people or thousands of
people that have poured you know their
life into like trying to help that
person
yeah for sure I read an essay by Arnold
Schwarzenegger recently which was I am
NOT a self-made man and he dissed him at
the same point it's like people ask me
all the time as a self-made man but he's
like let me stop you right there because
you don't see these all of these other
people all the other input
conclusion su come into the picture
first or opening of the gym Shih Tzu
came in cuz I saw some Gracey videos and
I was like I want to try this I season
right Gracie they it was products of
Gracie's in action and the footage of
the Cheetahs touching the hopper effect
they like VHS 90s Susan's like a ate
rice exactly their early early days like
man but yet so much I mean like that saw
those videos and I was like whoa like
another team is able to do this to
another human like I have to learn and I
went in and I got choked out by a girl
and I was like super quick douchey
triangle chose me slapped it on I was
like out you know and I was like
wrestling club level but still like
preparing to go to the Nationals in good
shape wrestlers love doing triangles
whole away from worse you know she's all
bad habits like god I really want a demo
triangle choke now but well we're going
to save that we just got our heads all
done we just got time
so the Jiu Jitsu I need to do that to
another human being
choke people yes must do that I saw her
this chick do this to this guy she
described she did it to God it was like
200 pounds and I was like how could that
how could this be
yeah did you Jitsu then did you get
bitten by that bug before opening the
gym or was it concurrently what was the
timeline on that a little bit before
I've been training for a few years and
then I'm you know open the gym actually
chose to pursue a fight in MMA like
within a couple of months I mean it was
like soft though you know we on I'd
tried to do it by MMA fight before in
2007 and got denied and so the state
wouldn't commission other or the I just
have let a commission would sanction it
yeah it was it's a head Commissioner
he's in wheelchair actually he told me I
think this is amazing what you're doing
here for people with disabilities we
support you doing this and then at a
commission meeting wouldn't won't be a
problem you get your licenses the
amateur fight at Georgia and then like a
couple weeks before the fight like I
don't know if there's a big outcry on
the internet a lot of people had
opinions about things and said some
pretty gnarly stuff and it meaning my
sister's really crying reading some of
this stuff you know people saying you
know Kyle's a limbless freak show get
doing this to get back
and come take a chainsaw and cut off my
arms legs like me on TV too you know
like the black super classy YouTube
comments right yeah and so yeah it was
it was kind of my first time doing
something that's very polarizing like
that and it was a unique experience it
was also coupled around like the time I
just opened the gyms and training for
the fight you know and like some nights
like sleeping at the gym I mean it
opened opened it up and it was like
Coachella classes I'm like the CEO and
also the janitor you know somebody like
was in pukes during a workout got to go
clean the toilets like you know so kind
of all those things are going on
simultaneously trying to go in pair for
this fight which is like one of the
biggest events of my life and it was a
wild experience but they look back in
that it was amazing some of my best
friends actually some of them one of
them is here was a director of a
produced documentary on it
ESPN bought and then now it's on Netflix
but it's is amazing journey what's the
dot cold it's called a fighting chance
sponge yeah so that was your first time
sort of being thrown to the internet
wolf with something you know fingers
they're hungry oh I do know a thing or
two about that what did you learn from
that
would you take away from that that can
be I mean it is a really no matter what
a really difficult experience but you
also then that I mean you have your
family reading these things what what
did you learn from that or actually and
I could phrase it a different way you
can tackle it however you like if you
were to give yourself advice just before
getting into that situation what would
you have said have compassion form have
some empathy for them and understand
that like even you know all they're
doing is they're projecting my
capabilities based on their own
experiences in imagining like if I were
in Kyle's shoes then of course you know
like whatever then I would be able to go
do this or that and if you don't have
any experience because I've never
trained with you or whatever then it
would make sense a guy going into a
fight you know punching and kicking is
loud you know choking is loud all that
stuff it's like seems like crazy and
ridiculous
until we train together I can change
your perspective right but it's like so
they didn't you know in their map of the
world and their understanding then it
was like I get it it makes
if extents and at the same time in the
cage I got to sit in there and be the
first time in there looking out not as a
spectator but as a participant I was
like such cool view and it was like wow
like 99.99% of the people that said
those things would never have that view
because they're so busy talking [ __ ]
that they don't live their life to then
had that experience and I know there's
on a Teddy Roosevelt thing a quote you
know from a speech he gave
but this excerpt is called ban in the
arena oh yeah and that I really
encourage everyone here I mean to go and
check that out made a huge impact on it
man oh they are going to definitely
check it out you know and I also because
I was in the middle of getting dragged
through the mud at one point for some
like minor infraction on the universe I
don't remember what it was but just like
getting stoned to death on the internet
by some like minor contingent of rabble
rousers and I was just really down on
myself and I watched ratatouille Anton
ego review at the end I'm going to
probably take us back on track but check
it out that's awesome oh when you're in
the air Isabella and tell your Roosevelt
I got to answer that by ratatouille on
to the picture but manly enough for sure
a must read so you're in the Octagon or
the cage what was going through your
head as you enter like whatever stands
out in your memory when you're warming
up and like getting ready going towards
it or getting in it like what's going
through your mind so I started before
this like I used to like in wrestling I
had overwhelming like like competitive
like you know anxiety and like pre-match
anxiety like I would be overtaken by it
like it was and to the point where
eventually like wanted to know nothing
about my opponents and I remember like a
beatnik it was like super tough and it
was like afterwards my coach was like
did you know he was like a two-time
state champ and if I hadn't had known
going into it I probably would've lost
so really going in a fight I did so much
like visualization and you know
sounds kind of like woowoo but it was
like so much visualization then I think
kind of like I felt like I told my my
instructor my job my
Paul Creighton is his name my jujitsu
coach at the time I told him I was like
I feel like I've been here like 10 times
like this is like my 10th or 12th fight
because I had visualized it so much that
when I finally got there I was able to
be calm enough to be able to enjoy that
moment what happened in front so it
wasn't the most exciting fight in the
world my goal my strategy I wanted to go
and cut the cage corners off to be able
to use a square cage we're finding in I
wanted to be able to go and then work
the angles then hit most single or
whatever it was be able to go and drive
him against the cage and take him down
not much in kick boxer however if you
can imagine and so a lot of it in the
first round is kind of beating them
towards to come to me and kind of
uneventful so that a second second round
I was like press the action of pressing
him trying to cut the corners all that
didn't get him down and ate some just
jabs try the hardest shot I ate was
maybe in the second round and then in
the third round I was like screw this
reckless abandon I'm just chasing this
guy as hard and fast as I can like 90
seconds something they even they now to
like the guy I thought was like well
those guys want his treadmill now like
it was like more of a track event than
it was an MMA fight I'm like but you
know I'm gonna go out there and
eventually it was like screw this like
you know he's not going to come in and
engage then like I'm gonna force the
action I went and laid in the middle of
the cage on my back and he came and just
crush me on the liver and I was like oh
bad idea get back up all right Plan B
Plan B but you know and they give me the
Internet it was funny it was like so
many people said like Oh Kyle's
definitely going to die oh yeah
definitely going to die going to turn on
the TV
could be the first televised death you
know it was like my other someone I was
trained at Forrest Griffin at a time my
other like training partes forces before
he was going to fight Shogun who's like
legendary MMA fighters and they were
like force is definitely gonna die again
Shogun he ended up beating him that it
was clutch force is gonna die Kyle's
gonna die there's like this camps going
to provide the first to MMA that's like
you know but is whatever I didn't die
haha unless I did and it just actually
this is natural and who knows right you
know I didn't want to have to be the one
to talk about awkward let's go to
private
see just the training for public
exposure fight itself by far the most
valuable thing is that it's okay to have
people pissed off at me or like mad at
me or saying things about me and like
whatever and I was like okay I get hurt
at first it was like a red dot I was a
grandma stuff and I was like meh I don't
want to say that it didn't frustrate me
I remember like I wrote this like post
on the Underground and all that stuff
and you just like got buried and nobody
even replied to it it would reflect this
whole wave just kind of kept going to
good people talking about stuff that was
out of my control and I was like they
don't know I want to go and show them
and all that and I'm finally like you
know I think actors after it was done I
was like the experience of it was like
screw that like I don't I don't need to
convince everyone right you know there's
plenty of people that I don't need to go
in and convince yeah I mean there's it's
just we all walk around with this idea
and myself included we all do it right
but I try to remind myself all the time
that I don't have a freaking clue what
reality is
I don't know right I don't know and I
want to be out in the world like try to
figure that out and just give up my
assumptions and beliefs and whatever
those things are not be tied to any one
thing we do and see stuff right now it's
like the election - and I'll polarizing
every but they get and we go and get so
gripped like these beliefs on one side
or another and it's not that one side or
the other is better to me it's both the
same thing
it's like we have to sometimes be able
to go and see that like it's just it's
just our own perception it's just around
there's nothing to do with reality well
you also mentioned in a way I mean
something piece of advice is given to me
at one point when I was getting very
frustrated and it was not about people
who don't get it it's about two people
who do get it yeah don't worry about the
first group okay and everybody has to
read man on the arena it is very
important reading goes well with the
serenity prayer and I'm not a religious
guy but they actually go really well
together
what habits do you have practices
routines traditions anything to keep
yourself positive because you're one of
at least in our interactions one of the
most consistently positive and enabling
people for other folks how do you keep
that gun or like what are things that
you find help hmm
to develop that or maintain it for me
it's like I have to have those things
yeah it's like going to the gym like
it's not you read one book and you're
done anything like that I think that
right now that's probably the biggest
thing I'm struggling with in my life
you know I travel close to 200 days a
year and I'm like just you know just
beat up by that and like you know so
it's different all the time and that
sort of routine and structure is it's
definitely something that I've wanted to
add more kind of consistency you know
and I think that now I'm taking actions
towards creating that in my life I would
say the one thing that makes a
difference for me is I'm actually like I
can I can fake extraversion well but I'm
not unless then yeah I'll need well I
won't get it but I'll need like 20 hours
of sleep actually yeah so -
unfortunately not in the cards but these
you know and sometimes you get up and
you do it anyway even when you don't
feel like doing it yeah and that's the
thing the difference with like a
performer or like some of the high
performers you have to do it right even
when you don't feel like it but there
are plenty of times when I'm at speeches
and stuff like that where you know don't
you know I don't feel like giving a
speech that day they get up and do it
anyway it's it's really a lot of it the
biggest habit I think that I've been
conscious of lately you know there's so
much discussion and I've kind of talked
about this in the speeches too but it's
like this like the idea of why right
that's a big that's a big discussion I
think the missing link that we have with
that is there are like hundreds of why's
that are occurring simultaneously for
any given moment of why you're going to
go and do anything maybe thousands but
at least hundreds I mean right now you
could come up with like a hundred why's
on the spot you know if you had ten
minutes think about it of like why
you're doing this TV show yeah it not to
have like judgment over those things
some things might be business-related
some things might be making an impact on
people and they're all notes
it might be just so many different inner
things connected with that and really
what I've noticed is that's okay and I
get to go in then at that point kind of
select what is the one that's going to
be the most empowering place to come
from with this in this example you know
I was a young entrepreneur and reading
your books and like you know looking up
to you and like so if I come at it from
this perspective of like one of the
wives of me being here would be like oh
I want to do a good job for 10:00 right
but like that's not the most empowering
why I mean it can be part of it you can
coexist with the fact that like there
may be some people in this room right
now they're struggling with things that
are way more difficult than anything you
or I have ever faced and it's one thing
that either you or I could go and say
could make one bit of difference with
that person or people then that to me
matters way more than anything else and
I know that the you know all the other
stuff of like you know look good on TV
or leg do a good job pretend like that
would be taken care of is that you know
doesn't even matter just like just my
awareness is there that's what matters
in so many instances I've been
profoundly impacted by by veterans that
were also in some really rough spots
like I desperately wanted to serve I
mean I wanted to go and 9/11 happened
and you know we saw the planes go in the
towers I was like I want to go bad you
know send me and would have done
anything to go and you know it was a
high school right stas terrowin and all
that and got so many friends are in the
military now some of my closest friends
active-duty some retired some injured so
I'm not anybody that's ever put on that
uniform I have a tremendous respect for
and
but on several instances and times where
I've been feeling sorry for myself you
know and I mean I hate this word
motivational speaker
I like the motivational speakers
whatever they have the bad days too
right and moments where I feel like
motivating but then like I go and meet
some veterans and you know just had
these just powerful experiences and
things that like just just really
reshape the way they go and think about
stuff I remember I was just sharing with
them with some friends today about like
you know I went in a couple years ago it
was a trip just back to Walter Reed and
got to have to go and visit we actually
played the documentary fighting chances
we had the viewing at Walter Reed and
spent about an hour in this hospital
room with this one kid who had recently
been been blown up pretty bad he's 19 20
years old he was sitting there with his
bad and they said you know I mean it was
fairly recent that it happened and that
when he I was like invited him to come
down and watch the movie with me and you
know we had maybe intimate kind of thing
30 or 40 people in this room watching
the film and like you know hasn't seen
their reactions to when the people would
go and say the things they said about me
and then I'm a fight it was like
PowerPoint ever like some of them wanted
to strap up a show after those guys on
my wall you guys need to chill but the
you know to this one kid I remember of
15 minutes after the movie started in
like he came he was in his chair and
he'd been blown up really really high on
the blast both legs and like almost it
was really high and they said that I was
like one of the first times you got to
come out of his room and like the first
time that he come out of his room maybe
like like one of the first times ever
like since he'd been there and stuff
like that and it's like it put a
different feeling and perspective on it
because it was like it took away this
idea that like I needed to go and serve
with a rifle that you know but there
would be ways that I could go and serve
in other ways now and I'm still in with
you know every fiber of my being want to
go and find ways to go in and help
those that have been over there to
defend us from Ryan Minich no excuses
the book was published a decade ago is
there anything about the book that you
wish you could revise and I would just
tag onto that or add or remove for the
letter certainly your change and I don't
think we have time for that
no it's like I mean really like I think
a big I can answer that and summarize
that with it's a perfect snapshot in
time of who I could Kyle Maynard was at
19 years old and you know it's not
something you know a big weakness that
I've had and it kind of said top in
connected to what you'd say that even
like why speaking right why am i doing
that well why did it frankly is I don't
have a good answer to that because of
what it's always done in many regards I
think that the struggle sometimes that I
have now is that someone was like read
my book and have me come in and speak to
their group and that's awesome but it's
also like their map of who Kyle was is
is like the 19 year old version and like
I'm like might not even talk about
wrestling right it's like there's a lot
of other stuff talked about so yeah do
you have plans to write more books I do
and I mean I you know I can't give you a
PS excuses do I have it no I think
that's a big reason of why I have it I'm
kind of glad that I scream pain and
writing as long as my right totally I
actually kind of see severe post I'm
like that doesn't sound like a lot of
fun ya know but it's it takes a lot out
of you and at the same time I'm like you
know a book is a very permanent sort of
medium you know I don't know if I'm
someday if I'll have kids or not I have
a niece and nephew you know and someday
they'll have kids and all that right and
they're kids and so like way after I'm
gone and when after you're gone those
books will still be around it's sort of
a way to for people to know who you were
yeah I always tell people and they're
like yeah I really want to write a book
like maybe my spare time and I'm like a
mediocre book is more of a liability
than a help trust me I can't pull that
one I can't put the toothpaste back in
the tube miss Devon that
that's a really messy operation is not
going to work when you are traveling
what does a workout look like you you
the pain cave yeah how do you create
that on the road
I try to mean I know that just with my
body alone I can go and make a lot of
different things happen different body
weight things and you know I mean if I
have one dumbbell or something like that
I can go and use it it helps for me to
have like a little bit of a mat or
something like that kind of yoga mat or
something that grace off of but
generally there's some form of even like
any type of object right like you know
if I need to pick up this chair and go
and move it around really faster than a
bunch it might look really weird for
anybody that comes in on that but like
you know it's I'm just imagine the
cleaning lady's right what is happening
right now totally I got to get out of
here that guy is definitely on drugs I
don't want whatever he's got to make me
move a bunch of chairs everywhere
worse recreation Ultra ever if you had
to give TED talk on something that you
are not known for do you have any comes
pet obsession things you geek out on
that so you'd present on I mean it's a
little bit different but I would say
it's I'd probably give a TED talk on
parenting but not from like every 90
kids right so like who am i picture to
talk on that but like so seeing my on my
sister as a parent is really special my
niece was diagnosed with type 1 diabetes
you know and some days are like really
hard to that like that's a disability
that you can't necessarily always see
less you see maybe like a glucose
monitor on someone or infront palms but
like you know my sister's just I know
she's just awesome with that like it
just is really special like the other
day you know the original issues at this
birthday party and this little girl came
up to her and she could see that she had
like a glucose potter in the back of her
arm it was princess themed birthday
party and this little girl was like you
can't be a princess because you have one
of those and my immediate response was
like oh well you can't be a princess
because you're the devil
I think that's a fair response I think
it's a fair response I think use
head-butter yeah that's right the little
girl that's working in Oh first we got
it on YouTube right it's like don't make
me break that talking about the so how
did your sister handle that and she's
like she'll talk to her about it and
it's just like [ __ ] in this like very
you know coping open loving way and like
yet sock so you know and like dealing
with like the reality of it but it's
really like they you know she won't let
her be consumed with this like identity
around like that the type 1 diabetes you
know and it's like and kind of teaching
her even at a young age like yeah I mean
if you want to do something someday to
be able to make a difference with this
like you can yeah it's like you know
she's like 4 years old and she's like
just the sweetest girl in my life I mean
it and she's I think that that too
in kind of her being around me and other
things like that's kind of given her a
level of like you know indifference
about the disability which i think is a
really good thing again difference
there's like zero separation it's just
normal and I had the only time that
she's ever said anything when my niece
where we were we were coloring together
and it was just like Elsa you know I
also know and I kind of like a thing
that we're coloring and she was like
looking issues like okay you don't have
hands
I was like yeah uh she was like huh my
back color is amazing like wait okay
I was tool right Maynard James Keenan in
tool he's like uh-huh he's the man and
like I love and also cheese of black
Dalton's you should do wrestled it was
army yeah I saw a guy that tried to get
on stage with him one time got past
security and the guy was like went to go
and give him a hug and like Maynard
what's it like did mahogany hate pasta
took the guys back rear naked choke
the guys like rocky doubt it Maynard
starts singing again and like then the
guys can just draw like this bad stage
run up on right to you he's a guy where
I'm like I just wanna so
Maynard goes and gives up he's this
music grey still doing it but it's like
he's had this super successful career in
music completely gives it up recreates
himself as a winemaker I know you didn't
know that no dude you're like the wine
guy I like right I mean it you have a
consumer basically I drank like I don't
even know like my body weight many times
over now that cuz of you I thought for
sure you know that oh oh yeah no I mean
look I'm not gonna I am a consumer
hollow and capacities well I mean why no
it's like a brutal business super brew
it's kind of like especially with with
the exception of a rare few it's kind of
like okay if you want to okay I remember
I asked this buddy of mine I was a bunch
of bars and I asked him why he didn't do
restaurants like why don't you have food
on your menu and he goes I would rather
he's put into a window he's like I would
rather put my hands behind my back jump
through that window face-first take all
my money and light it on fire in the
street and start a restaurant they
explained it but as I get kind of
indifferent to it you know are just like
magazines newspapers restaurant so you
probably should just let your money on
fire and then winery just like with the
exception of a handful of people very
hard to make work
yeah rural brutal and you're at the whim
of actually God right yeah I mean like
totally do a bad season you have a bad
season
thank you I make her so the most
interesting people because I think the
ones that I got to Argentina in this
last climb when we were in the land of
Malbec and spent time with this guy the
the wine was Ellen and me go and add
this like you know super masculine like
half Scorpion half man
label but it said at the end there's
only one battle that you remember and
it's a battle within I mean of course
I'm like this could be terrible but I'm
going to love it could be that cause
yeah the guy was like testing limits and
testing assumptions where he was growing
grapes with altitudes that like people
said you couldn't do it yeah and I love
that you know it's like I love that
you're you know can go and test those
assumptions it's like no that was you
know patient it's a medicine it's and
everything I mean I just got to give a
speech with visor and I talked about the
treatment that my grandma went through
with this you know in cancer you know I
called you treatment products are some
of the things they go and make and it
did polarity that occurred and the
detention that occurred and inside of
our family and how that treatment should
go was really intense and it finally I
like you know she was dealing with
oncologist that hadn't had you know they
went to school that were like maybe 40
or 50 years ago right and I was like
there at the very tail end of their
careers and they're not updating the map
right now there's so many things like
even I'm fasting has had you know kids
demonstrated profound effects on um you
know radiation and chemo treatment say
oh yeah it's incredible I mean you know
Dominick D'Agostino I've interviewed a
few times incredible scientist has
looked at the effects and it doesn't
it's not effective for all types of
cancer it's not suitable for all
patients but there are published studies
looking at how it can sensitize cancer
cells to different types of treatments
while protecting the good to healthy
cells yeah it's very very fascinating
stuff and I just want to mention one
thing which is we're talking about how
everyone has everyone's like Swiss
cheese and we all have our disabilities
to some are more visible than others
perhaps yeah so Malbec this is and this
may be an exaggeration that's also
common in Argentina very sensitive
people they love telling stories but
Malbec was not really well known in the
world before our Justyna but it was
brought from Europe and my understanding
is that it was basically treated like a
garbage grade and and then the
immigrants brought it to Buenos Aires
and it turned into this world-famous
wine that was
scarred infected so never know where
you're going to find strength the
garbage great madness maybe that's a
book right seriously I think about this
I'm like every one of my favorite
societies to go and study of like the
Spartans and the Vikings in these
warrior cultures they would like what we
did I say this will throw them over the
edge like this beginning is 300 is
throwing the baby laugh like that would
have been me right there like clearly oh
my god so many amazing images coming on
my weekly United yeah I'm still thinking
about you unlike coke moving your
furniture well the night is young
young yeah love a party uh which I'm you
get the chandelier from when you had the
initial idea to do Kilimanjaro to the
point that you were actually suited up
geared and about to start the climb how
much time elapsed so sitting in the
bathtub
hey no sea ice had the idea that was
like fall of 2010 met my friend Dan
April 2011 and we started this project
together and then April 2011 and then by
January 3rd 2012 we were on the plane
fly in Africa good to figure out a lot
of stuff I mean I mean first was getting
something that's crazy enough to take us
yeah seriously cuz it was like so how'd
you convince him to do it ah it was
rough I mean moving we I think so
thankfully one of my friends and mentors
this guy named Erik Weihenmayer that was
the first blind Mountaineer to climb
Mount Everest and every high peak in the
world and he actually just rafted the
entire length of the Colorado River
through the Grand Canyon Wow right not
rafted like in the raft he was kayaking
red wine oh wow
completely laughs like it's not like a
like you peek through like you know when
you I put blindfold how do I do that
it's really crazy to think about that a
while and like he's insane he's amazing
and you know I saw like saw em out mean
my friend Dan who helped me co-create
the mission and we you know Dan was
first one it was kind of like one crazy
not to go along with me he'd you know
he'd been a
record-setting middle linebacker it was
you know use like five foot nine or
something like that you know and like
had twenty one on us in tackles in game
if it was like one of the most just
passionate esoteric you know just guys
that we like to connect with on that
level almost burnt my house down Museo
couple and it's a really random story
but yeah he like microwaved and aluminum
coffee mug and I was doing some emails I
turn around there's flames shooting out
of my way right like bro so I hope you
sees this but you know so it's like but
he's this kind of guy though that was
like he'd go and run through a brick
wall yeah and I needed that person to go
and have that belief with me so then
from there we sought out Eric Eric
introduced us to her guide Kevin shrila
Kevin had led he'd managed Eric's base
camp their barracks Evers climb submit
to the base camp manager he led he's led
more climbers up Kilimanjaro than I
think any American and many with
disabilities led a guy almost to the
true summit and like a hand-cranked bike
group of like eight climb flying
climbers up Kilimanjaro
so with Kevin he was really the one that
you know him and his partner Kristin and
kind of made it happen well I would just
want to thank you
Kyle for honestly showing everyone that
they can do more than they think they're
capable of doing to huge gifts to the
world thank you gentlemen
I'll mannered
hey guys this is Tim again just a few
more things before you take off number
one this is five bullet Friday do you
want to get a short email from me and
would you enjoy getting a short email
for me every Friday exact provides a
little morsel of fun before the weekend
and five bullet Friday is a very short
email where I share the coolest things
I've found or that I've been pondering
over the week that could include
favorite new albums that I've discovered
it could include gizmos and gadgets and
all sorts of weird [ __ ] that I've
somehow dug up in the the world of the
esoteric as I do
it could include favorite articles that
I have read and that I've shared with my
close friends for instance and it's very
short it's just a little tiny bite of
goodness before you head off for the
weekend so if you want to receive that
check it out
just go to 4-hour workweek dot-com
that's 4-hour workweek com all spelled
out and just drop in your email and you
will get the very next one and if you
sign up I hope you enjoy it
this episode is brought to you by
99designs I've used 99designs for years
for all sorts of graphic design needs
whether you need a logo website book
cover anything else 99designs was
created to make great designs accessible
to everyone to make the process of
getting design much much easier so when
I first started out for instance testing
prototype covers and getting prototype
covers for the 4-hour body
I want the contest drop that is one
option this is a great solution fielding
for fast affordable design work and the
ability to choose from dozens of options
risk-free let's say you need something
late night quick turnaround well people
in other times other countries can also
help you solve a problem since then I've
worked with 99 designs on a separate
path or a different option and that is
the one-to-one project service so in a
number of cases and I'll give you one
example when I wanted to create the
cover for my audio book The Tao of
Seneca this was a very important project
to me I decided to use their one-to-one
project service and with this service
you can invite a specific designer to
your project agree on a price and then
work together until you're satisfied
they allow you
it'll rate my feedback and all this
stuff and I haven't shared it yet we
also got something incredibly good
really some of the best illustrations
I've ever seen from using this
one-to-one project service with a
handful of different designers and
illustrators they blew my mind 99
designs makes this all very easy and
efficient so you can check out the Tao
of Seneca design and other work that I
and your fellow listeners for that
matter have done on 99designs at 99
designs comm forward slash Tim and right
now you can get a free $99 upgrade on
your first design again that's 99
designs com4 slash Tim this episode is
brought to you by wordpress my go-to
platform for blogging writing online
creating websites everything I love
WordPress to bits my site every site
just about that I have is run on
WordPress and the lead developer of
WordPress Matt Mullenweg has appeared on
this podcast many times the very first
episode in particular is amazing the
second I took a ton of those on so you
should check it out
but WordPress where do I even begin I
mean the New Yorker uses it jay-z
Beyonce they use it 5:38 TechCrunch Ted
CNN time whether you are looking to
create a personal blog a business site
both neither or something else
you'll make a huge impact when you build
your website on wordpress.com and
directly from some friends at Google I'm
not going to quote them by name but they
say that WordPress offers the best
out-of-the-box SEO the search engine
optimization imaginable so if you're on
WordPress you immediately have a leg up
on everybody else on search engines and
so forth in my experience I'm no medical
doctor of search engine optimization but
I will say that I used WordPress for
years and fell in love with it to the
extent that I became very close friends
with Matt and then became an investor
slash advisor to automatic which runs
wordpress.com that is how much I believe
in this that's how a lot of my
most successful products and investments
have come about because I'm in love with
X and then I seek out X nearly 30% of
the Internet is run on WordPress and
that includes everything from the huge
sites that I mentioned to neighborhood
sites and it is super easy to get
started there's no need to worry about
security or upgrades or hosting they
offer 24/7 support and handle all of
that
which allows you to focus on creating
the highest quality content you can with
the least amount of friction I don't
have to worry about downtime I don't
have to worry about getting emergency
emails if I'm on vacation or something
like that and WordPress is my go-to
solution for all of this I trust all of
my most important text on the Internet
to WordPress and they can't buy that
with a sponsorship they can't buy that
with anything I want
uptime uptime uptime and quality and
that is what I have selected after
everything that I've looked at so check
it out go to WordPress that's wor DP re
SS com wordpress.com forward slash Tim
seriously 15% off of your web site today
that's wordpress.com forward slash pimp
[Applause]